Cuál es la importancia de renovar este
mandato
bueno ante todo muchas gracias por la
invitación y el espacio la importancia
la
verdad es exagerar se trata del único
mecanismo independiente de Naciones
Unidas con el mandato investigar
violaciones a los derechos humanos en
Venezuela con dos objetivos muy
específicos diferenciados pero
complementarios en primer lugar
garantizar o contribuir al derecho a la
justicia de las miles de víctimas de
violaciones sistemáticas y generalizadas
de los Derechos Humanos en Venezuela y
por otro lado garantizar que las
personas perpetradoras las personas
directamente o por mando responsables de
estas violaciones rindan cuentas ante
una justicia Imparcial y por lo tanto la
perspectiva de que no se renueve la
verdad sería muy restrictiva ahora Cuál
ha sido la respuesta o la cooperación
del gobierno venezolano durante estos
años de trabajo
tanto en 2019 cuando se creó la misión
de determinación de los hechos como en
su primera renovación en septiembre 2020
las autoridades venezolanas dieron una
impresión no genuina de cooperación que
se ha reflejado en la realidad en el
hecho que no han implementado las
recomendaciones que ha hecho la misión
no han permitido el acceso de la misión
al país No han colaborado ni reconocido
el mandato de la misión de determinación
de los hechos pero tampoco han
implementado la recomendación es
realizadas o la gran mayoría de las
recomendaciones realizadas por la alta
comisionada de los Derechos Humanos ni
tampoco por el examen periódico
periódico universal donde se hicieron
cientos de recomendaciones por
cantidad de Estados miembros de Naciones
Unidas Entonces no las perspectivas de
que el estado venezolano coopere son
mínimas pero continuamos Llamando a que
cooperen de forma genuina con la misión
de terminación de los hechos señora del
campo ya se han presentado dos informes
sobre el trabajo de esta misión en
Venezuela y un tercer documento se
conocerá en octubre qué vamos a
encontrar en de transporte
bueno es importante Resaltar que con
cada reporte se va pintando una imagen
mucho más completa
de La complejidad infinita de la
violaciones a los derechos humanos en
Venezuela el primer informe llegó a la
conclusión de que se Podrían haber
cometido crímenes del lesa humanidad en
Venezuela el segundo informe resaltó y
detalló como los operadores de Justicia
como el sistema de Justicia lejos de
garantizar Un fin a esas violaciones
facilita que esas violaciones se cometan
y este tercer informe Esperamos que a
donde en estos patrones que se han
documentado y en particular también que
resalte la realidad que se vive en el
arco minero del Orinoco una realidad la
verdad es que muy opaca donde muy pocas
organizaciones tienen acceso ya sea
dentro del país o desde fuera y por lo
tanto ese aporte va a ser imprescindible
pero siguen quedando temas Por
investigar